y en France 24 como todos los días
hablamos de salud para eso nos acompaña
más Romero mar bienvenida bienvenida a
ti también María Clara Bueno este once
de marzo se cumplen tres años desde que
la Organización Mundial de la Salud
utilizó la palabra pandemia para
referirse al covid 19 que ha pasado
desde 2020 Sí recordemos este 11 de
marzo de 2020 había 118 mil casos de
contagio registrados y 40.291 personas
que habían perdido la vida para que nos
hagamos una idea de la magnitud de las
cifras Y cómo han cambiado en tres años
no ese virus que había empezado a
contagiar a la gente en wuhan entre
noviembre diciembre de 2019 y que en
2020 desató una crisis que pues creo que
ninguno de nosotros se podía imaginar la
pandemia esto También es importante
recordarlo no es una categoría oficial
de los agentes internacionales para
definir una crisis sanitaria eso es la
emergencia de salud pública
internacional que se declaró en enero de
2020 y que a día de hoy sigue vigente y
precisamente por no ser un término
oficial es muy difícil saber Cuándo
empieza pero también sobre todo cuando
termina no Cuándo podemos decir que la
pandemia ha llegado a su fin sabiendo
que el Kobe 19 hoy en día todavía afecta
a miles de personas Eso sin quitar que
por suerte hemos dejado atrás quizás los
momentos de más crisis o de más tensión
por ejemplo los sistemas hospitalarios
alrededor del mundo funcionan con una
relativa normalidad la disrupción en la
vida cotidiana es mínima Aunque pues
también es un buen día para recordar que
hay personas con comorbilidades o
personas mayores que en algunos casos no
siguen viviendo con estos miedos porque
su vida sigue estando en un mayor riesgo
si se contagian de Kobe 19 bueno y
quiero que hagamos ese Paralelo que
usted mencionó rápidamente porque hace
tres años se hablaba de 118 contagios
Cómo son las cifras ahora pues Estamos
tan acostumbrados a las cifras y 2020
nos inundamos tanto de estas cifras que
parecen haber perdido por ejemplo su
magnitud por eso trajimos esos gráficos
a día de hoy hay 759
41 millones de personas que se han
contagiado de covid 19 más del doble
para que nos hagamos una idea de la
población de Estados Unidos estos son
los casos nuevos que han habido cada día
a lo largo de los tres años y vemos algo
muy interesante y es que a pesar de que
por supuesto durante el primer año fue
el momento más crítico de la pandemia a
nivel de efectos de salud los picos más
grandes llegaron con omicron a inicios
de 2022 y también a finales de 2022
inicios de 2023 con las oleadas en China
Sin embargo a pesar de que en esos
fueron los picos de más contagios el
impacto en la salud pues pública global
fue mucho menor Y creo que eso habla
bien de como el mundo pudo prepararse
responder rápidamente a la pandemia
cuando vamos a las cifras de las
víctimas mortales que quizás pues es una
de las partes más trágicas uno de los
rostros más duros de la crisis de salud
pública del covid-19 aquí tenemos los
picos vemos que son al contrario de los
contagios no Aunque había menos
contagios había muchísimas más muertes
al inicio y eso se ha logrado ir
reduciendo estamos hablando de que por
ejemplo el pico más alto fue en enero de
2021 se llegaron a registrar
14.400 muertes en un solo día unas
cifras Pues que a nivel de salud pública
difícilmente se habían visto antes las
cifras oficiales cuentan que En total
son 6,87 millones de víctimas mortales
las que se han registrado en estos tres
años sin embargo hay estimaciones de la
OMS que elevan esta cifra podrían llegar
a los 17 millones no es una calamidad
definitivamente a nivel emocional social
y también económico y como usted lo dice
la pandemia del covid-19 también fue una
calamidad a nivel emocional porque Más
allá de los muertos y los contagios esta
pandemia también generó muchas
enfermedades mentales por los meses de
encierro que tuvimos Sí yo creo que
vernos encerrados la incertidumbre no de
que podía suceder nos hizo hacer a todos
Muchas preguntas y darnos cuenta también
de la importancia que tiene cuidar este
aspecto de la salud el de la Salud
Mental sin embargo es cierto que el
impacto real de la pandemia y sobre todo
encierros de 2020 sobre la Salud Mental
está un poco debatido a día de hoy tres
años después sigue siendo una incógnita
realmente la magnitud al menos en
términos de cifras en general el relato
no es que pues la depresión o la
ansiedad aumentó una investigación de la
Universidad de queensland que se publicó
en delante es quizás la más conocida al
respecto de este tema concluyó que en
2020 había aumentado 76 millones de
casos más de ansiedad y 53 millones más
de casos de depresión sin embargo eso
como decíamos sigue estando debatido y
es un ejemplo de cómo tres años después
seguimos teniendo tantas preguntas
abiertas todavía alrededor del impacto
de la pandemia hay un estudio
recientemente publicado esta misma
semana en bmj en el periódico de
medicina que desmiente un poco eso y que
básicamente dice que los cambios no
fueron tan significativos de
estadísticamente y que fueron en
magnitudes muy pequeñas aquí dan unos
indicadores digamos a que los valores
positivos significan que sí hubo un
aumento pero como vemos son todos muy
pequeños no la población general el en
la Salud Mental general 0,11 sí
reconocen por ejemplo que en las mujeres
tanto en los casos de Salud Mental
general como en los síntomas de ansiedad
o depresión Los indicadores son un poco
mayores digamos a oscilar alrededor del
0,2 sin embargo nos recuerdan eso que
son Pues básicamente señales
estadísticamente muy pequeñas o incluso
insignificantes sin embargo bueno algo
que es importante reconocer es que las
cifras de este estudio se dieron sobre
todo en países de ingresos altos o de
ingresos medio altos y puede ser una una
imagen muy distinta unas cifras muy
distintas tienen más lejos en países de
América Latina no donde la interrupción
por ejemplo del trabajo informal fue
mucho mayor y creo que la incertidumbre
económica la carga de las mujeres
también puede llegar a ser mucho mayor
sobre todo con un sistema que no te
sostiene de la misma forma claro y otra
de las caras de la pandemia Omar ha sido
la vacunación que probó ser exitosa
probó ser exitosa o sea claramente
amortigua el impacto de la pandemia lo
estábamos viendo en esos gráficos de
antes no amortiguó una increíble
mortalidad y esa saturación de los
sistemas de salud se desarrollaron
recordamos en un tiempo récord Aunque
siempre con el gusto agridulce de una
distribución desigual no de la
acaparamiento de vacunas por los países
ricos de la negación también de las
farmacéuticas a abrir las patentes y el
conocimiento para que las vacunas fueran
más accesibles sin embargo Pues también
para terminar este espacio queremos una
buena noticia que daba ayer el director
de la Ops escuchemos
el segundo nivel más alto de cobertura
de vacunación en el mundo con el 71% de
cobertura de vacunación contra la
covid-19 poder decir esto no que el
continente de las Américas es el segundo
con más tasa de vacunación del mundo
claramente ha sido un esfuerzo muy
grande porque muchos de estos países
tampoco tuvieron la posibilidad de
comprar de primeras las vacunas del Kobe
19 Así que hay un esfuerzo que queremos
reconocer también el día de hoy de
sistemas de salud personas voluntarias
convencer a todo el mundo de que se vacu
Ne Y todavía hoy en día pues si lo
podemos hacer sigamoslo haciendo un
esfuerzo que ha sido máximo y que no ha
sido nada fácil a todos ellos
felicitaciones mar gracias por toda esta
información Muchas gracias María Clara